[Music]
along with a brand new Sci-Fi Adventure
that has plenty of talent behind it
we're bringing you a spin-off of a
popular comic book based series a horror
franchise that's turning almost 20. a
dramedy about sticking it to Wall Street
and an animated spin-off series based on
a classic video game it's all coming up
on this week's let's watch
[Music]
hitting feeders is the Sci-Fi Action
Thriller the Creator the first reason
check this one out or run in the
opposite direction is the eerily
familiar premise about a future war
between the human race and AI forces
which have developed a mankind killing
weapon surely that will never happen in
real life right another reason is The
Talented cast led by John David
Washington which also includes Gemma
Chan Ken Watanabe Sturgill Simpson and
Allison Janney and when you're not
hearing their voices you'll be hearing a
score by Hans Zimmer which is always a
good thing especially in theaters the
third reason to give the Creator a try
is its creator as in director co-writer
Gareth Edwards the Godzilla and Rogue
one director has already shown some
serious chops and this one seems to be
taking it up a notch he said Classics
like Apocalypse Now Blade Runner Rain
Man and E.T were sources of inspiration
for this film and wow what a great list
of movies to pull from
hero it's not about Glory
it's about sacrifice
arriving on Prime this week is the new
series gen V this show is a spin-off of
the boys which became a surprise hit
back in 2019 and hasn't slowed down with
three certified fresh seasons and that
shows Creator error Kripke also worked
on gen V the first reason you're going
to want to watch this one the second is
that this show is based on a story arc
from the boy's comics about a group of
young superheroes AKA soups where being
battle tested at a school for crime
fighting run by the antagonist
Corporation vat and if you know the boys
you know that a bunch of young hormonal
and competitive soups all together in
one place probably isn't the best idea
Reason 3 is that the first season of gen
V is set concurrently with the boys
season 4 and with some of the boys we
already know and love popping up like a
train Soldier Boy and the Deep man I
miss those guys
I still have a lot of work that needs to
be done
[Music]
not to be confused with Gen V opening in
theaters this week is the horrorflix saw
X now the only thing scarier this
weekend than saw X might just be this
fact currently saw X's Tomato Meter
score is the only saw film in franchise
history to be fresh that's right after
nearly 20 years of saw with only the
original score at 50 percent rotten
coming even close saw X is sitting
comfortably in fresh territory now it is
early and you can't expect the score to
change however the general Outlook
towards this entry is the most positive
the franchise has ever seen and that's
more than good enough reason to play the
game this weekend and for reason 2 how
cool is this it serves as a direct
sequel to saw and a prequel to Saw 2
with Shawnee Smith reprising her role as
Amanda Young from those movies as well
as the third and sixth installments of
course Tobin Bell is back too as John
Kramer AKA jigsaw in the movie and this
is the third reason to see it Kramer
ends up in Mexico weeks after the events
of Saw after hearing of a miracle cure
for his cancer but what he finds is a
fraudulent scheme run by people who need
to be taught a lesson and who better to
teach than jigsaw plus if you don't
watch it you know he's coming for you
right A lot of people feel the system is
broken
the whole idea of the stock market is if
you're smart and maybe with a little
luck you can make your fortune certainly
not anymore
there's no hope for the little guy
also hitting feeders for its wide
release is the film dumb money this
biographical dramedy is based on Ben
mesric's book The anti-social Network
about the GameStop short squeeze in
January of 2021 AKA went a bunch of
every man turned the tables on Wall
Street if you're not already sold here's
another reason to get smart with dumb
money the ensemble cast we're talking
Paul Dano Pete Davidson America Ferreira
Sebastian Stan Shailene Woodley and Seth
Rogen seriously we could name more but
they told me to stop Nick Offerman
thirdly since this is the wide release
that means it has been reviewed plenty
during its limited release and it's
already certified fresh at 84 on the
Tomato Meter the consensus from critics
calls it a crowd-pleasing dramatization
and rousingly entertaining surely we had
you at rousingly
of light the Messiah
I pledge my service forever
[Music]
and finally hitting Netflix is the new
adult animated series Castlevania
Nocturne reason one to rev up your old
favorite streaming service is that this
dark fantasy action show is a spin-off
of the Castlevania animated series which
has four very fresh seasons of course
both are based on the popular Dracula
themed video game franchise and reason
number two to watch Nocturne is that the
story comes from the 1993 game entry
Castlevania Rondo of Blood and 1997
Symphony of the Night 90s video games
for the win and with that is the third
reason this show follows the descendant
of the Belmont family Richter Belmont
and is set in 1792 during the French
Revolution as you know French Revolution
setting for the win always
[Music]
all right fresh fam there's five picks
to make this week the best last week of
the month so far trust me it makes sense
be sure to let us and your fellow
viewers know in the comments what you
did check out whether it was on this
list or not remember to check out
rottentomatoes.com for the latest
updates on scores and reviews for
everything mentioned as well as the
movie and TV World At Large thanks all
for today fresh family until next week
stay fresh